forty-five-year-old renee compeon was
lifted to safety this week
after spending the night lost in the
wilderness
but it's how he was found that's the
real story
the avid hiker lost his way in southern
california's angeles national forest on
monday
he spent the night in a makeshift
shelter hiding from a bear
and mountain lions i was like thinking
like i hope they don't come over here
because i don't have anything just i got
a stick and rocks just in case they
would get close to me
weakened and dehydrated kompeon made his
way to a ridgeline
where he was able to text a single
picture of his location
to his roommate from his dying phone the
roommate gave the picture to the l.a
county sheriff's department
who posted it on social media asking
local hikers
if they recognize the surroundings i
sent them the location right here
and they actually found them right about
there satellite mapping enthusiast
benjamin kuo happened to see it
and helped rescuers narrow down the
hiker's location
quo's gps coordinates matched cell phone
data the sheriff's department was
already using
and helped the search team pinpoint
compeon's exact location
i was like thank god they found me like
i
i was like a tear came out a little bit
like i like i'm safe thank you everybody
for
your efforts and for helping in the
search
so i'm grateful that that message got
out and that everybody did what they did
amazing technology you're like the
the mountain lions roll in i know and
yeah and the bear comes and you're like
come on get me out of here you smell
that fresh blood
off the rail